hello folks welcome to rational science
i had a big headache throughout the day
today i was about to
postpone to class
lecture
took a couple aspirins a couple hours
ago and
much better now so
on with the show
okay
uh
for those of you who are not aware
there's a war going on
okay
you know like rick van winkle he woke up
after 20 years you know maybe you just
woke up you don't know there's been a
war going on
yeah it's a war against a disease known
as covid
holy what am i saying
sorry uh
no no
take that i'll take that back no that's
something that happened a long long time
ago
a disease that killed trillions of
people but
it's been a while now and nobody
remembers that anymore
no no there's another war going on
closer back here in europe
just in case you didn't hear right
it's a war between the united states and
germany
and it's about to be over you know
germany uh
has
uh pulled out the white flag
and surrendered okay
and that war is practically over
there are some more things to do but
essentially you know germany has uh
capitulated
and uh what it is is that they forced
some draconian conditions upon germany
and because of that you know the one of
the things that happened they had to
shut a pipeline
cost i think around 12 billion
bucks
and that's dead so they forced that down
and they force also
germany to
stop a banking system
transfer of money international money
known as swift
they forced germany to
increase their defense budget by 112
billion dollars
and some other draconian conditions
essentially germany has capitulated and
the the interesting part is they did it
without firing a single shot
and losing a single man
i think it's the first time in history
where um one country takes over another
without you know losing a man or firing
a shot
that's incredible first time in history
probably
anyways there's also a little skirmish
in a
a little country out there called
ukraine
and
russians are killing russians over there
apparently there's
a province of russia that wants to
become a new country he wants to secede
from the union
and so the russians are killing russians
there you know
and because of all these wars
you know uh people are starting to ask
questions about
the unthinkable you know the
nuclear war the third world war
will we ever use the nukes
and uh
for the politicians is pretty good for
people to talk about that because then
they forget about the economy
you know uh keeps their mind busy on
something else
and so people are thinking about nukes
will we ever throw them do we have any
protection against them
one fellow today uh sent me a note and
he asked about the iron dome you know
supposedly a uh
a um
protection against nuclear bombs
and uh so he asked me you know uh does
the
iron dome protect us against missiles
in general terms you know maybe he meant
more in particular you know whether it
protects us against nukes coming in
those missiles right maybe that was the
issue
and so i told them uh what what you see
there i said uh they're designed for
short range these this iron dome
protection right it's designed for short
range low altitude and small missiles
small ufos
okay
and they can be overcome this defense
system can be overcome by
shooting many missiles so imagine
someone
throwing one ball and you have a
baseball bat and you you know
hit that ball well that's pretty good
you know maybe hit a home run
but imagine if they throw 10 balls at
you well you can't hit all 10 of them
you know and that's one of the problems
with this uh
missile uh missile defense system
and the other one is uh mother nice ebms
you know i don't know if all of them but
a lot of them are designed with multiple
warheads so when they come up you know
when it
enters uh the space where it's supposed
to hit it breaks up in several
bombs so you got like 10 bombs being
sent everywhere upon re-entry
and you know the the protection there
even if you had some kind of protection
might uh be able to protect against one
of the missiles maybe a couple but not
against several of them okay so
some of those will hit their target okay
so if you think that uh you have some
kind of umbrella that's going to protect
you against nuclear missiles
well maybe think again okay
then
part of it is the speed of the incoming
missile how fast it's going can the
shield protect you against something
that's going very fast
well you know um
some people makes the mouse traps and
other people
uh figure out a way out of it you know
and so uh every side develops this you
know has this arms race they develop
antidotes to new weaponry
uh and it's just an ongoing thing you
know and so
i don't think you can eventually protect
against all this stuff
no matter what you do no matter how
smart your engineers are your
physicists technicians
can't protect against everything
and i doubt very much against nuclear
weapons
and then the last point there is that
you know the public uh knows relatively
little and i mean by that you know the
news organizations that print all these
news and do the research
uh they don't have the details of some
of the
of some of these weapons
that
information is not publicly available
very few people know about them they
sign confidential and secret agreements
and etc etc right
and so uh we don't really know what kind
of uh problems they might have
you know so we don't know everything
that we need to know about them so if
you want to take over the world like
pinky and the brain you know uh well
think again um
you know
you can throw the bombs
but you may not be able to protect
yourself against bombs okay because
there is no
no way of protecting against that now uh
some time ago
it was in 1983 we had uh reagan and he
kicked started the famous star wars
and that was a strategic defense
initiative or sdi okay
and um
you know that lasted for about 10 years
when they finally canned it they said
well it's no good they couldn't protect
themselves against russian missiles okay
so clinton stopped that
and then they had other things going on
in between but up to 2019 trump signs
the mba the national defense
authorization act
and with that you know he um he started
the thing again in other words uh the
united states is developing weapons and
anti-weapons you know defense systems
and the russians are certainly doing the
same thing
and a lot of that stuff is secret we
don't really know all of what's
happening there only a few people up
there in the high places know about it
but i'm saying a lot of that is
irrelevant anyways because um
what's the deal the deal is that um as
you can see we have satellites there
running around the world and
you know with a satellite
you can kill
other salaries you have killer
satellites okay and when you have that
you have no more internet
forget about the bombs forget about the
nukes in fact hopefully if if you're
gonna die you better die with a nuke
because it's instantaneous
unless you're far away and you get
radiated but if it hits you you know
it's it's over for you right we're done
you never have to worry about it again
but if they kill the satellites
it's going to be a slow painful death
which is going to be starvation because
suddenly there will be no money on the
planet all our money now is on the
internet they kill the satellites they
kill the internet
and you can live without water you can
live without food you can live without
air but no one can live without the
internet
okay
so uh if they happen
to kill the internet because they start
messing around with the satellites and i
think uh the united states and russia
both can do that maybe the chinese maybe
some other countries japan india i don't
know
uh you know once they get up there in
space and they start killing the
satellites
it's all over
you know because they kill the internet
and the internet's where all the money
is
it's all but abstractions right
anyways uh
the war out there you know the all these
wars they're good especially the the
talk about nukes
that's very good for presidents uh and
other leaders right uh politicians
and you know for a president to be
president during a war a war president
that's good
until he loses
if he loses all bets are off but as long
as he's not losing
the people stand behind him
you know uh in argentina uh we had uh
the military takeover kulit
sponsored by the united states by the
way and they overthrew the
constitutional government
and there was this fellow there was a
succession of presidents all military
folk one was god tied he was the last
guy
and got kiri started a war the falkland
war my venus war as we call it and
he starts this war the falkland war
and the people were all behind them they
forgot all the tortures all the things
that the military had done and they
stood behind him because it was you know
all this nationalism going on
well that lasted only until they lost
the war
then they then they wanted his they
wanted to ring his neck they wanted to
hang all these military guys you know
because not only did they lose the war
but now the
uh notions
that the military had tortured and all
the problems that people had came back
and so right now people are forgetting
economics and they're concentrating on
wars
and nukes and stuff like that and that's
good for a politician it's also good
because people stand behind them
okay
and you know a lot of these people have
learned
from
from the master of them all and that was
nicolo machiavelli macabelli
wrote a book his name
titled the prince
apparently
it was
uh based on in general terms on caesar
borgia who was the son of a pope
alexander borgia and they were um
they were of spanish descent
and uh caesar borgia was
like the perfect politician he knew
how to handle people from up there
and what uh machiavelli his main
argument was that you know that
it's better for a politician to have
people
fear him
than to love him
okay so if you're a politician up there
you don't want people to love you you
want people to fear you not so much that
they hate you but just enough that they
fear you
and one of the masters of that was uh
stalin stalin
you know he he
uh commanded respect
and the way he commanded respect was he
would kill the people around him
his ministers you know
especially people who were uh
you know who came up the ranks with him
you know you had people like kamianev
and zinoviev who were right-hand people
of lenin when lenin died you know stalin
came up the ranks and he pushed these
guys aside and eventually had him killed
because these were at the same level as
he was originally
and he kind of had to get rid of them
because these people thought that they
could be a
you know on a par with him so he had to
get rid of him
and what he did he put new people you
know to be his ministers and so on and
when those came a little too close to
him or starting taking some attributes
that they shouldn't have uh he had him
killed in fact uh there's uh
i think i got it here uh they had uh
a lot of the pictures you know famous
pictures of stalin where uh people
disappear from the pictures and here you
see a couple examples of that you know
you've got uh one father who apparently
fell into the pool
into the water
and in the days of lenin you have this
fellow also disappear there because uh
he was he wasn't considered communist
enough or pro-stalin enough
so you know uh people like stalin they
they followed machiavelli and a lot of
people like biden all those as far as i
know all of them have read or at least
know about machiavelli and his
uh way of running government says you
gotta have people fear you okay and
that's one of the reasons you know these
guys talk and they you hear them on the
news every day saying oh we're gonna
kill you and you better come down and
discuss with us or or we'll make life
difficult on you you know they have to
be tough
and so people think oh i got a tough
president i've got a tough commander out
there and you know when they sit down at
the table
uh they talk a little differently maybe
you know
and one of the questions that you should
uh ponder is why aren't those
discussions between countries why aren't
they public
why are they always absolutely always in
secret
so they have all these dealings in
secret they're not the press is not even
allowed there
right
and they have all these discussions in
secret then they come out and they tell
the public whatever they want each side
tells their their their people whatever
they want
and you say why aren't those
conversations public i mean if they're
going to discuss what one country
proposes and what the other one
uh proposes in exchange you know what
the what the uh back and forth is
why aren't we all privy to all that
information why is that all secret
think about that okay
anyways uh yeah they they have to um
they they have to have uh
uh all these uh discussions one on the
one hand they also have to have you know
people fear them to a great extent
and again as long as uh people like
biden you know their
war presidents and the war lasts and he
doesn't lose the war well he's doing
okay and the same goes for
putin on the other side as long as
he doesn't lose the war
he's more or less okay
and i think he's in a tougher situation
i think whether
putin wins or loses he's going to lose
here you know he's going to be in bad
shape either way i think he can't win no
matter what he does you know he's in a
tough situation
okay anyways uh that's more or less
what's going on out there in the world
incidentally uh you know uh uh
talking about machiavellian how uh uh
people how the people up there really
think
you know you've got the case of stalin
again you know and he had a famous
saying which i absolutely love shows how
cynical he was
and it goes something like this he says
if the loss of one man if one person
dies one man dies
that's a tragedy
if a million people die
that's a statistic
so he could care less how many people
you know how many peasants uh died in
the uh in the fields out there you know
starving or whatever he could care less
and politicians are like that you have
to be like that if you're a politician
you got a tough situation you got to
look the other way and say well that's
just the statistic
and you know he was such a
kind-hearted
person
as a as a dad you know he uh his son
tried to commit his oldest son tried to
commit suicide many times
and he ended up in the hospital a couple
times i don't know exactly what he tried
to do
but uh stalin said about that he said
he said
he can't even do that right
that was his comment
okay one fella says here uh he says uh
the population has not gone up linearly
like that i was showing uh
uh rise in population and then
collapse and so on
in fact i was showing that you know in
the at least since the 19th century
population on earth has gone from 1
billion to 8 billion
now that's a big jump in just 100 years
we haven't had that many people in the
rest of humanity almost you know
and so he says it's cyclic
during the dark ages the population
peaked and then went down with the
plague population goes up and down in a
cycle
absolutely not
absolutely not this fellow knows very
little about demographics hasn't done
any research obviously yeah in the 14th
century uh there was a plague apparently
a bubonic plague
uh mid-century killed maybe uh half to
maybe one-third of the population of
europe
uh those are the numbers based on
the little towns they showed in the
books they how many people died so they
collected a lot of these books and they
said well it looks like maybe one third
to one half the population of europe
died
and uh
but the population was very young in
those days
everybody died at the age of 20 you know
on an average
uh people died very young especially
babies they died a lot because they got
sick with traditional you know
childhood diseases
and so they would die and a lot of
people would die in wars also you know
because it was man-to-man combat
and uh and also because sickness and war
go together you know you have sickness
in war you kill more soldiers and
probably them with bullets or arrows or
whatever
but
that happened in 14th century and
population picked up real quick because
the population was young
that's a totally different situation
than what happened since 1963
which is when the population pyramid for
the whole planet for our planet as a
whole
overturned
and right now the problem is we have
older and older people in the world
people like me and fewer and fewer
younger people you know age 20 and
whatever
so
we have a different situation our
population pyramid has overturned and
there is absolutely no way of
overturning it again
nothing humans can do
mark my word nothing humans can do to
get the ball rolling again to have
people
have children again
right now the
growth of the uh birth rate the birth uh
rate the growth uh rate
is uh becoming smaller and smaller and
smaller as you can see in the chart
there and if everything goes according
to plan according to how it's going now
we probably won't uh
by mid-century we should reach zero
population growth we will reach a zenith
of uh the number of people that ever
that
the
most people we've ever had on earth
and then from there it's going to be all
the way down and i think it's going to
happen way before mid-century
i don't think we're going to make it to
mid-century at all but that's just my
take on that but for sure there's no way
we can overturn
uh the population pyramid again it's
overturned now it's standing on its head
and and now what's gonna happen instead
of being like this it's like this
okay or getting to be like that that
means um there's gonna be more older
people fewer younger people
and once those older people start dying
and we're not producing new younger
people
uh that leads to a collapse of our
population and this is more or less what
it looks like okay
that's uh more or less the history of
almost any species okay this is what the
curve looks like a species starts out
for a long long period of time where
births are greater than deaths
okay
they're approximately equal to death so
births slightly are higher than deaths
at some point births
wait way close to the end of the species
life by the way uh the births uh become
less
approximately equal to dust but a little
lower
and
uh and then eventually we have the
bursts much greater at much less than
deaths we have lots of dust and few
bursts so that's what a population
curve looks like for almost any species
okay and so guess where we're at now
we're at that zenith there where we're
turning that corner that curve on the
top
and we're about to go extinct
okay that's my take on that
so uh no
um
population doesn't always go in cycles
it goes in cycle only until it reaches
until the population pyramid or the
demographic pyramid overturns once it
does for any species it can't
uh overturn it can't
overturn again i can't undo that
it's that at that point just goes into
extinction okay and that's what's
happening to humans now we overturned
the population pyramid in 1963 for the
planet as a whole and from there on
we only can go down means our population
is increasing but the population growth
rate
is becoming smaller and smaller and
smaller until it goes down to zero and
then from there it goes negative okay
that's the
idea okay a fellow says
says there will never be a time when
nobody accepts money
at least crypto
i know a bunch of people who will always
accept money
that includes me
okay uh i'll buy your car and i want to
give you
uh my
shirt it's a little uh dirty it's got
holes in it but
hopefully you'll take it because
anything can be used as money
okay and so i want to use that as money
i want to buy your car uh will you
accept my
shirt
you might say well you know i don't want
your shirt
yeah but it's money because anything can
be used as money well you don't like
that i'll give you some vietnamese money
will you accept that instead
no
uh how about i'll give you limestone
prime limestone okay rocks good rocks
okay limestone rocks
will you accept that
and you might say no i don't want any of
those things
well i thought you said that you'll
accept money any kind of money
and you say crypto well you know i mean
uh do you think if you would have
offered crypto
to ruth
in the bible who worked for barty for
food
she worked in the fields collected uh
barley and then she was given a little
bit of party to take home to hers for
herself and her mother-in-law both of
them were widows
and uh do you think she would have set
crypto
or even worse
or better you could say you know um
what if what if you say look i'll offer
you
10 euros
upside down
i'll offer you 10 euros if you work the
fields for me
and
she says
you're gonna offer me a piece of paper
yeah but see this is 10 euros you can
buy a lot of stuff with that
that's just a piece of paper objectively
right
do you think she would have accepted
paper
2 000 plus years ago
probably not
and likewise you know today i don't
think women will work for
barley not even the prostitutes will go
for party
we'll work for food
i don't think so so all that is
contextual and crypto is just a number
what in in the matrix out there
uh i don't know if uh people will wanna
you know as long as you have faith in
crypto yeah you can do something with it
but if nobody accepts crypto tomorrow
you know why would you wanna have this
number
in uh
in you know floating around in
in cybernetics
that's nothing it's just faith
money is just faith
trust in god we trust right that's all
money is
so to say that you will always accept
money that you'll always accept
uh crypto
well think again all these people have
been brainwashed so much with money with
the world we have today
they cannot think outside of that
you know go and offer a crypto go and
offer 10 euros dollar bill or a dollar
bill or whatever to a pygmy that's
hunting out there in the jungles
offer him a little piece of paper and
say look i'm going to give you 10 euro
i'll give you 100
if you catch uh you know an elephant for
me
the guy says what you're going to give
me a piece of paper i give you an
elephant you give me a piece of paper
you think i'm crazy or what
see people like this fella you know
they're the sink the the ship sinks
and you know while bill gatey goes in
there and goes to the kitchen grabs all
the food he can get to go to the island
this guy grabs the treasure chest he
might even sink in the ocean trying to
grab that treasure chest and he swims
with this all the way to the island he
says i got the treasure chest
what's he going to do with a treasure
chest on an island
these people don't understand that when
the global economy collapses when money
is no more that's what i mean by global
economy collapsing money is no more
nobody accepts money you can have all
the crypto all the dollar bills all the
you can be a millionaire it's going to
be worthless garbage that you hold
the only thing of value in a jungle
is food
in the asphalt jungle the only thing of
value is food you don't have food
what was the show in the uh 1960s have
food will travel
that's more or less the way it's going
to be you don't have food
well it's going to be the difference
between the haves and the have-nots
the haves will be those that have food
and the have-nots will be those that
don't
and they'll be known as dead
okay but this will take a while for him
to understand all that
okay final issue fellow says says
uh what do you think of terra mata hut
okay uh did heidelbergensis and
neanderthals uh have huts with wood and
skins
well i can do is give you my five cents
worth you know this so-called hut
uh
is allegedly anywhere between 200 and
400 000 years ago depending on who you
talk to depending on who you believe
and there are different takes on that
what they found is a few stones there
and so on and
some people say that they belong to
different ages first of all that the
river kind of
took them into this
place and so you got different uh ages
in the same location
and the guy who studied these uh for the
first time he said oh stones uh
some um some other things there and he
says
with this i uh he concluded he
inferred
that someone had built a hut there
and
i think very few people accept that in
general and one of them is me i don't go
for that i don't think that 200 to four
hundred thousand years ago whether
heidelbergensis or nand earth all lenses
uh built huts
i think uh especially neanderthals and
certainly uh
even their ancestors uh the or
predecessors the ancestors or the
heidelberg or the homo erectus
um
none of them built huts i think they all
lived in caves that's what i think that
that's how they sought protection
and they guarded their territories where
they hunted
and their enemies were other
neanderthals other heidelbergs other
uh homo erectuses
and
they protected their hunting grounds and
where they lived was a hot a a cave not
a hut so i don't think they built huts
that's that's my take on that and i
don't know maybe there was some
exception some
neanderthal that ventured into no man's
land and he kind of had to protect
himself from the rain or from um
uh lightning and maybe built something a
you know makeshift uh
tenth of some kind
could have happened
but i don't think it was the norm if if
it ever happened
again my take on that five cents worth
okay
okay let's move on to the subject matter
of today and we have uh
the oh no hold it we have another issue
we have the loonies we still have the
loonies there are some loonies who
believe that the moon spins
and
you know i've gone with this already
several times now i thought they they
get it by now but no some people are
fighting it they say no no the moon
spins the moon spins bill you got it
wrong
okay so here's one fella and he says the
following
it says the moon is title locked to
earth this is synchronous rotation not
spinning
uh
rotation
uh see rotation is an ambiguous word i
already mentioned that in the past but
this guy
has you know he's a little
solid in the head you know
made of a single piece or maybe nothing
between the ears whichever way you want
to see it
rotation uh is an ambiguous word it
could mean orbit or it could mean spin
and so when you use rotation all you're
doing is obfuscating
the issue because you're not clarifying
whether it's orbiting or spinning so you
should not use the word rotation or any
synonym we should leave it to two words
spin and orbit but those are clear cut
people more or less distinguish a spin
from an orbit okay so anyone using
rotation is just trying to obfuscate the
conversation so that he doesn't lose his
religion that's what it's all about
and he says spin doesn't require an axis
and it's fast motion
the moon does one rotation
so uh on its own uh imaginary axis so
what's the difference between rotation
and spin we'll never find out from this
fellow for sure okay
uh he said one is fast the other one is
slow i guess that's all it is but
they're both around the axis
spinning around the axis whether it's ro
rotating revolving
you know orbiting it's all the same to
him you know so we need to distinguish
these words
and so that's one fellow
uh here's another
not one but two other fellas and they
say the following
i've watched three videos about spin and
i never seem to hear why
the rod pounded through the earth is
moving but the rod in the moon is steady
and another fellow says something
similar said why is the earth axis still
neither access is fixed
i'm wondering why are these poor people
in science why did they come to science
sites
i mean these people should be you know
at the monastery you know
cleaning latrines
you know for for the church or something
or maybe lighting candles i don't know
what what all these altar boys do out
there
but these people don't belong in science
they don't have the mental capacity to
be in science okay
let's see if we can clarify for all
these poor
folks that were not blessed by their
mothers you know and they they got to
bring that you know maybe the scarecrow
left behind
okay
so let's start at square one let's see
if we can go slowly
and i'm sorry for all those people who
do understand i just got to go slowly
for the people who don't understand the
uh little students who fall back into
class right okay let's see if we can
bring them up to speed
okay so let's start at square one does
god exist
that's the million-dollar question
well the guy might say well yeah god
exists
okay why did you arrive how did you
arrive at that conclusion why do you
believe that god exists
the guy said well one day i was puking
my guts out in the bathroom and i
prayed for salvation and jesus christ
came and talked to me and oh my god
sorry but that's that's not how we do it
in science okay
we don't do it like the atheists do it
we don't do it like the agnostic to it
we don't do it like the theists do it
we do it the scientific way
and that goes against atheists
theists and agnostics all three of them
okay all those are unscientific
okay how do we do it in science well the
way we do it in science is we define the
word exist
otherwise we have no idea what we're
talking about when we say god exists or
god doesn't exist or maybe god is there
so i don't know if god exists i don't
know if i can prove them you have to
define the key words that make or break
your argument
so the first world you have to define is
the word that no one has defined in the
last 10 000 years which is the word
exist
you need to know what the word exist
means before you can say god exists or
god doesn't exist
i hope that's clear to someone out there
okay you have to define the word exist
no one has defined the word exist ever
we still don't have a definition for the
word exists what we have in the
dictionary are synonyms uh what is being
living
reality real those are all synonyms we
can't use those synonyms you can't
define
a word
scientific word using synonyms or
antonyms okay
so we define how
physical presence
physical stands for object presence
stands for location what does exist mean
an object that has location
okay now we know what it means now we
can use that word to make our case now
you can understand what we're talking
about because we have defined the word
uh exist as object that has location
okay
and so now a person might say well we
have to define the word god
because we need to know what the word
god means
the answer is no
we do not define the word god
i hope that's clear it's a big no we
don't define the word god
first we have to determine whether god
is an object
or a concept
concepts we define
objects we don't define
we point to objects so the et the
klingon
understands what we are referring to
when we mention the object called god
so you point say table you point and you
say dog you point and you say tree
and you point and say god if that's what
god is
if god is a concept love
intelligence
energy
then you define it
okay so we don't define god first we
have to determine whether god is an
object or a concept then if it's a
concept we define
okay
okay so uh moving on here here we have
um
god uh is got an object or a concept
uh concept we define and objects we
point to just like god is doing right
there okay so
that's the first thing we have to
determine
okay
so i hope that's clear
uh people can always ask questions later
on okay uh
and we'll see if they have anything to
say about it so what did we do here
first we defined
define the keywords because we're going
to make a case we want the other person
to understand what we're saying
so we have to define
in this case this example the word
exists in order to talk about whether
god exists or not
okay is that clear i hope so
okay so now let's go on with spin
is jupiter spinning
and someone might say uh yeah it
looks like it's spinning
how did you come to that conclusion
you might say well i see the red spot
going around and around periodically
looks like it's spinning
and i say um
what spot
i don't see any spot
the spot the big red spot you know that
jupiter has it's going around and around
and around
well i'm sorry i i forgot to tell you uh
i was born blind
i don't see anything i'm blind i'm also
quadriplegic i can't use my hands to
feel the surface to find out if it's
spinning or not
so what do we do now
well maybe we do what we do did with the
word exist we have to define the word
spin objectively so that we know what
we're talking about
and that's what these this individual
who said who came three times and hasn't
figured out what this is about it's
about defining the word spin
that's what it's about
so why does he ask this stupid question
like why and the other followed the same
thing
this is not a wide question
where did they get this why means
they're not even paying attention they
don't even know what's going on here
and a guy came three times
tells you a lot about you know some of
these people
now we're trying to define the word spin
so that we know whether we can use it
that way we can use it consistently and
say the moon spins or the moon doesn't
span jupiter spins jupiter doesn't spin
the top spins the top doesn't spin we
can talk intelligently because we have a
definition
but it turns out in ten thousand years
not a single mathematician defined the
word spin
and that should not surprise you because
spin is a word that belongs exclusively
to physics
mathematicians don't know anything or
they understand anything about physics
so they never define words for physics
they define words for mathematics
okay that's the problem but then they
extrapolated or attempted to extrapolate
these words of mathematics into physics
that's what's happened okay
okay so the first thing we want to do is
eliminate again synonyms and antonyms so
this other file who use the word
rotation or rotate okay he's trying to
use synonyms because he's trying to get
away with murder
and that's what happens with all people
who are afraid to lose their religion
you know the so they use these
ambiguous words like it's rotating but
it's not spinning
but what did you mean by that what do
you mean by rotate does it mean spin
does it mean orbit does it mean uh
any of those uh you know gyrate uh cir
to circle it around to spiral what are
we talking about
you know so the guy uses ambiguous words
on purpose because he wants to obfuscate
the
situation the discussion so that he can
get away with murder
and in science we can't allow him to do
that so what we do is the first thing we
do is do this we eliminate all synonyms
and we leave the words that allow us to
talk clearly okay
so we're going to talk about spin and
orbit
we don't need orbit because we're not
going to be talking about orbit really
but i just want to distinguish these two
notions one is
you orbit like the earth orbits around
the sun
that's one thing that's not what we're
going to talk about we're going to talk
about spin okay and the question is what
does spin mean
right now we have this to turn around an
axis this is the notion that people have
out there this is condensed version okay
you might find other words in there but
essentially this is it to turn around in
axis
what does that mean
and the reason i ask what does it mean
is the question is whether to turn on an
axis means that the axis itself is
turning
or not
and the reason no mathematicians ever
discovered this
is they use a one dimensional axis
and the problem there is that
you know there is no such thing as a one
dimensional axis
so how did all this start what started
with a religion known as geometry
in fact it's not a religion it's so it's
strictly irrational
geometry is an attempt to merge the
language of mathematics with the
discipline of physics it's the first
attempt by humans to merge these two
uh you can call them disciplines even
though mathematics is not a discipline
it's a language that's all it is it's
like trying to unite i don't know
hieroglyphics with physics okay
mathematics is a language
and the language uh was set up wrong
when it when it was
when they attempted to incorporate that
language into physics and the first
attempt was geometry and they screwed it
up
completely and they could have screwed
up worse
so we have an irrational
you can call it discipline now
uh known as geometry which it has rotten
foundations to the core
so let's go through that real quick so
that we understand what the problem is
from from the roots okay here here's the
problem with geometry okay
we have the zero d point
what is a zero the point
you know uh euclid said no part meaning
or interpreted or translated as zero d
no dimensions dimensionless
and they represented with a
two-dimensional three-dimensional dot
they put a little
smudge
okay on there and they said that's the
point
what do you have objectively in front of
you well you have a 2d or 3d dot
and so you look at that say okay that's
a dot
but that's not zero dimensional looks
like it's
two-dimensional maybe three-dimensional
but certainly not zero dimension
but it gets worse because that dot
represents a non-dimensional concept
known as location or position as
mathematicians call it
so let's see we get this right we have a
zero dimensional
point represented by a
two-dimensional or three-dimensional dot
that actually represents a
non-dimensional concept known as
location
well that makes a lot of sense that and
and
keep in mind geometry is founded on the
point that's the
first thing that euclid put in his book
elements right the dot the point the
location
okay
which is the foundation of geometry and
to this day by the way okay that's how
it's plotting that's what's you'll find
all over the planet
okay so now we go to the 1d line what is
the 1d line well it's a row of points
maybe
or maybe it's a trajectory of one point
of one location because that's what a
point is point is a location so now we
have something very
very
scary which is the movement of a
location
okay
so it could be either a row of locations
maybe a row of apples occupying those
locations those positions or maybe it's
one position one location that is moving
tracing a an
itinerary and they call that verb
a line
they represent it with a what a
two-dimensional plane elevated plane and
they call that a line
so we have a two-dimensional
uh elongated
rectangle
called line
that represents either a row of
locations or one location that is moving
from a to b
okay
and what are those locations zero
dimensional or
non-dimensional locations
you're following me
the whole thing is rotten to the core
the foundations of geometry are
irrational
okay
now where do we continue with this well
we have the imaginary 1d axis
what is that it's a 1d line what was the
line a series of locations or maybe
you know a row of locations row of
apples or the movement of an apple from
a to b i don't know which
okay you can take either one okay
but it's a one-dimensional
line
what's a one-dimensional line what's a
one-dimensional axis
well it's an imaginary one-dimensional
axis is
unimaginable you cannot imagine a
one-dimensional anything
and people say well i can bill you can't
because you're not intelligent you can't
you can't figure this out but i can't i
can imagine a one-dimensional line a
one-dimensional axis
well if you're so smart
why don't you put it out here so that we
can all see what's in your mind i want
to see it on paper or maybe bring the
one-dimensional
thingy you've got in your mind to the
conference and show us
and yeah you can't put the
one-dimensional out here because you
cannot even imagine it there because if
you close your eyes and visualize the
one-dimensional whatever you've got in
your tiny brain you will notice
that it's at least two-dimensional
otherwise you cannot imagine it meaning
that you can make an image
of that even in your brain
and if you think that's hard try the
zero dimensional dot the zero
dimensional point the non-dimensional
location see if you can imagine that
what are you going to imagine for a zero
dimensional or non-dimensional nothing
and that's what the line is made of the
1d line is made of zero dimensional
locations
so it's all rotten to the core you
cannot imagine 0d 1d or 4d or beyond you
can only imagine make an image of
picture you know pictorial
2d and 3d that's all you can that's the
best you can do
you can't do zero one or four and above
okay
and so what's the problem well the
mathematicians never figured out because
they're using the one-dimensional line
the one-dimensional axis
right
and what they're looking at they don't
even care about the one-dimensional axis
or light they just care about the
distance from that reference point that
frame of reference
to the edge of the thing that's
supposedly spinning
so imagine a ball
and you're looking at the location at
the edge of the ball the surface of the
ball with respect to a location along
the the so-called one-dimensional axis
they get rid of the axis they don't need
the little line they don't need that
little strip that's there only for
pictorial purposes they're only going to
use the distance
the separation actually the distance
traveled because they're only concerned
about meters feet inches whatever
whatever unit they use so they're just
going to take and say well did the
distance traveled
change
if it did then it's spinning
but see they're only looking at numbers
they're not looking at physics they're
not looking at the physical thing to
find out if the thing is spinning or not
that's why when they say well does the
moon spin they say well it does spin why
well because it's
rotating around its one dimensional
imaginary axis
how can it rotate or how can you use a
reference whatsoever
uh the 1d
axis how can you use that if it's not
something physical
and and the issue there is that you can
imagine a three-dimensional
axis turning like you know that uh thin
uh barber's pole
you can say well that's spinning you
know you can imagine that spinning right
because you can picture it you can
imagine it spinning because you can you
know you can make a picture of it in
your mind you can watch the movie
you can't do that with a one-dimensional
axis
and because you can't do it with a
one-dimensional axis the mathematicians
never figured out whether the axis was
spinning as well
why because they cannot imagine a
one-dimensional axis spinning because
they cannot even imagine a
one-dimensional axis to begin with
you can't use the one-dimensional axis
to talk about spin
spin belongs to physics one-dimensional
belongs to the religion of mathematics
to mathematical physics not even the
math because math has no use for the
one-dimensional anything math uses
distance traveled that's what they're
concerned about
okay so this is where the problem starts
and that ends there okay
okay so what's the story here well
here we have a ball orbiting
ah there it is
uh a two-dimensional two-dimensional
okay uh barber's pole you could say
maybe a uh
axis
but a two-dimensional one
so that you can take one edge or the
other edge of that
line that is a line there
two-dimensional okay that's what a line
is two-dimensional remember you have to
be able to picture it no such thing as a
one-dimensional line especially now for
the purposes of physics at best you can
say three-dimensional
but you know you can maybe mimic it with
a two-dimensional and still make your
case like i'm gonna do now you can say
that that ball which is represents just
the location on the edge
of a
sphere for example could be a cube could
be anything that's spinning right
if that location which i'm representing
with a ball here okay i'm going to do
that just play a mathematics on you
right i'm going to use a ball to
represent the location it's just a
uh
you could be an atom it could be
an electron whatever you want uh on the
surface of a physical entity so you can
say it's an atom
yeah you can picture as a ball whatever
you want it doesn't matter because we're
concerned about defining the word spin
that's what we're gonna doing here for
those people who've been here three
times haven't figured it out yet we're
trying to define the word spin that's
what it's so this is all about know why
please don't ask why stupid questions
like why this is defining the word spin
okay okay so uh is the ball spinning
well if it's changing its distance with
respect to each of those edges of that
two-dimensional line
then it's spinning
if it doesn't change the location with
it because the
pole two-dimensional pole is spinning at
the same rate as the ball
then it's not spinning
okay do we have that so we're gonna be
defining that so here let me show you
another picture of this so that you get
a an idea where i'm going with all this
here you have the moon is the moon
spinning
and you would say well no it doesn't
look like it's spinning to me because um
staring at it
it certainly doesn't look like what a
top would look like that's spinning
that's just the point if you're moving
together with a moon around the earth
and always staring at the same mountain
same valley or whatever
is the moon spinning according to your
perspective and you say well no it's not
spinning according to my perspective
which again shows that subjectivity
you know seeing touching has nothing to
do with what we're talking about here
it's got nothing to do with the
definition of the word spin you cannot
define the word spin using see or touch
okay we're blind we're quadriplegic we
can't touch we can't see
so whenever you have problems close your
eyes and you'll be safe
work with the definition
we need to know what the definition of
the word spin
means or what it what it is you know
what it represents okay so let's look at
the definition of the word
give
spin
a second here
and here it is that's why we need to
define the word spin so that we can talk
intelligently and there you have the
definition of the word spin
surface changes distance with respect to
a 3d axis
okay so you have atoms
on a 3d
now you can talk about imaginary axis
because you're going to run a an
imaginary axis through the earth or
through the moon
and the only issue here is does that
axis spin together with a surface or not
that's the only issue
okay if it does if it spins together
with a surface the thing is not spinning
only if it's standing still and the
surface changes its location with each
with respect to each atom
of that three dimensional axis
do we call it spin
that's the definition
of in physics of the word spin
okay do we have that much
okay
and uh so yeah you can see that the moon
is not spinning because the
the barber's pole is spinning together
with a surface at the same rate and you
would see always the same face if you
were spinning if if you were moving
around the earth together with a moon
you would always see the same face so
you can't say that it's spinning
and you can't talk about rotating we
don't use that word remember it's a
four-letter word we don't use that
it's only people who try to defend our
religion that will use the word rotate
or some other word similar to that now
we say if it changes
the distance the separation okay with
respect to the axis then it's spinning
if it doesn't change its
distance
it's separation
then it's not spinning
that's the definition
you might say well i don't like your
definition bill
it destroys my religion you're raping my
virgin
okay so uh this is the way we do it in
science okay just for those of you who
are interested in science that's the way
we do it
uh you must define the word you got to
get into ring and fight for your
definition your solution is easy come up
with a definition
that is
for a better mousetrap
you can't use tradition you're going to
say we've always done it like this this
is what we've always used you can't use
democracy all the mathematicians voted
for my definition and you can't use
authority well that's what i found in
the dictionary
now there's not a single definition in
the dictionary that is scientific
okay so don't use the dictionary ever
because all the definitions are
unscientific they are ordinary speech
you have to come up with your own
definition and fight for it in the
coliseum you got to get your sword your
shield and defend your definition it's
the way it works in science
hopefully we got that straightened out
as well so you don't like my definition
no problem come up with a better mouse
trap and be able to defend it i'll be
glad to tear it to pieces okay
okay and uh so
here's a corollary to all that and it
comes from this gentleman his name was
thomas kuhn
and he's famous for
inventing the term or the notion of
paradigm shift
and this was his notion okay
he said uh paradigm shifts scientific
revolutions alter the very definition of
science itself
so we redefine science
you know
17th century so-called scientific
revolution defined the notion of science
that they had since the days of the
greeks
and they screwed it up because they said
science is math and
experiment
descriptions
and we're saying something different
today we're saying no science is not
description science is explanation
and that's something totally new
they've never done that they've never
done explanations do we have an
explanation today
of how
a magnet attracts another have you ever
found one that you can sink your teeth
into and say oh i know how a magnet
attracts another do we have an
explanation of how gravity works why uh
you know a pencil
right
falls down and not to the sky do you
have a
rational
explanation for that or are you still
using warp space time
you know a concept
so no we don't have explanations
emanating from the establishment every
time you push them for an explanation
they say well we don't know we're still
studying someday we'll figure it out
so that they don't have an explanation
for anything
all they have are descriptions why
because mathematics can only describe
they equated math with science we are
doing a paradigm shift and saying
science is not descriptions science is
explanations
we got that
okay
now yes let's move on
to uh
subject of today which is this
thing we call big bang what is big bang
well big bang i'll tell you what it is
in a nutshell it's
uh
how the universe got started
we can say it's the creation of matter
or worse
it's the creation of
nothing of space
gets very scary after a while
but where do we start well we start
first with the explanation that we've
always had from traditional religions
and here it is
uh you go to the good book one of them
uh christianity says in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
okay and so god waves his magic wand
and he creates the universe
earth and the whole heaven everything
right
uh what's the problem with this well as
you can see we don't know where god came
from god was already there
so this movie starts at frame number two
we don't know what happened in frame
number one
okay
and you can maybe argue and say well
there's been no frame number one god's
always been there so that frame is
eternal it's been he's always been there
okay uh you know that's debatable that's
something we we have to think about
so uh you know god had no mother okay
great
um
what does the religion of mathematics do
well they have the same thing except
that they got rid of god
and so this is they still have the magic
wand they have the black magic
and and it creates this universe but
what they've done is got rid of god okay
they said we we can do creation but
without god
it turns out that um
they claim this is not true either
see hold it what do you mean it's not
true i thought
big bang was the creation of the
universe of matter
not quite
you got it wrong you understood wrong
they say
okay and so
what does
mathematics say what does the religion
of mathematical physics say well they
say the following they say um
that
their movie also starts at frame number
two just like christianity
they don't know what happened at frame
number one and they started frame number
two and today we're at frame number x
okay but they don't have any they don't
have any clue what happened to frame
number one they don't even attempt to
explain what happened at frame number
one they cannot tell you the mechanism
that led to
the uh start of the universe the
creation of matter
they always start at frame number two
and that's been this notion has been
around for maybe uh
40-50 years now
they had to revise the theory because
originally it was that
big bang was the creation of the
universe okay
or that was the insinuation at least but
they got away from that because you know
a lot of religious people kept saying oh
you mean
there was a frame number one and yeah i
know god made that frame right because
everything has to have a cause and god
made it so who created god well god has
always been there
so
you know they got it covered but science
so-called science you know mathematics
they have no answer to that so they say
no we we started frame number two
we we never go as far back as frame
number one
okay and here you have um
a testimony on that okay
the big bang theory is the prevailing
cosmological model this is out of wiki
uh the model describes not explains
right describes how the universe
expanded from what
from zero from frame number one
from name frame number two an initial
state of high density and temperature we
already had
density of something
lots of stuff there
compacted together
and lots of temperature
so there was something there
and you say well how did that come into
being you know what came before that
they said we don't know uh
the theory only goes as far as that
little dot that little singularity or
whatever they want to call it the big
bang starts at density and temperature
not at zero not at the creation
of matter and space
so you know one of the
issues that people should ask if you
haven't done so
already in your mind is
okay so
what is all this stuff
uh pushing against because okay we don't
know what came before that before the
singularity before the high density high
temperature
thingy that was there this little ball
or whatever i guess it's a ball right
we don't know what came in there but if
you have a ball if you have a something
there what's on the outside of it
because you cannot conceptualize that
little ball that singularity that little
dot
three-dimensional data i assume i don't
know maybe it's zero dimensional uh what
was on the outside of it
and when it exploded or you know when
this thing expanded or whatever you want
to call it
what's it pushing against what's on the
outside what's the black stuff
because if the little dot contains space
time and matter
well you can't say spaces on the outside
of that which is the black stuff there
that i had to put in there because i
don't know what else to put in there
they have to tell me what what's on the
outside what is it time
is it uh thought
you know maybe it's thought that's on
the outside i don't know what's on the
outside of that
and they say you're not allowed to ask
that question
oh okay okay that solves that problem
yeah so uh they don't have an answer to
that
and so um here's the picture that we
have okay
uh of the universe okay this is our
universe today this is the way they
visualize it they see our universe
according to mathematics right space
time and matter are all inside the
uh drinking glass there tilted drinking
glass okay
and apparently at 13.8 billion earth
years ago that's when it all started the
little dot
and again when i asked what's the black
stuff
that's
contouring the
this
uh drinking glass
and they say you're not allowed to ask
that question okay i won't ask it
anymore
i won't ask anyone it's unscientific
okay it's unscientific i'll take it back
i'm sorry i offended you
yeah you're not allowed to ask that
question it's a no-no question okay
okay give me a second here
okay uh so
um
when when asked about that you say well
then what's on the outside and one of
the answers you get is this
uh
finite by unbounded notion
they say look the universe is like a 3d
ball it's finite
but it's unbounded because you can run
around it forever and you will never
find an edge
and this is the most irrational
explanation you'll ever find in
mathematics okay because they're talking
about two different things the ball is
finite like all balls are finite even
cubes are finite
and you can run around a cube a ball a
triangle or whatever
and
you're not talking about unboundedness
you're talking about
incessant uh motion
that's what these people are confusing
unbounded with they use the word
unbounded when they should be using the
word incessant motion or running
incessantly
or perpetually or any any adverb you
want to use in there okay but never
um
can you use the word unbounded but they
see it's fun finite but unbounded
meaning
it's got a
it's got a perimeter but it don't
it's both they cover both bases duality
you know mathematics loves dualities
well they use the word unbounded
wrong they should be using the word
incessant and they use this all the time
they have all these mis concept
misconceived words uh they talk about
warped or bent space time
because the little photon you know
curves around they say
now if the little photon curves around
it should be called deflected not bent
light
or bent uh or or warped light that
gravity warps light no no it warps light
if if light is a banana then you can say
or a hammock or something like that then
you can say it warps the hammock it
works the banana you can't say it warps
the photon because a photon is a little
particle you can say deflects it
so they use the wrong words they use the
wrong language and they confuse people
because they're introducing words of
structure when they're really talking
about verbs about motion
okay this is a problem
serious problem in mathematics again
they never get the language straight
and so here are some of the fatal
problems with uh the
big bang theory okay
uh they never answer none of these
questions uh cause of big bang what
caused it they said well you're not
allowed to ask that question because we
don't know what came before that we have
no way of proving it we'll never figure
it out so don't ask that questions
unscientific it's philosophy
okay i won't ask it i tried ten times
now i won't try it anymore
origin of matter again we have no idea
they said no we start at high density
the matter was already there high
density high temperature and that's our
starting point frame number two in the
film okay
and uh you know we don't know how matter
was created origin of space that's even
worse remember the universe contains
space as well
and time
that's inside that's encapsulated within
the so-called universe
and so
you ask what's outside can i ask 11th
time what's on outside over there what's
all this pushing up against well you
can't say that it's time or that space
maybe it's against intelligence i don't
know
give me some words that i can put in
there i don't know what else to put in
there they say you're not allowed to ask
that question but inside the universe
you've got space time and matter
but listen carefully because then they
talk about parallel universes
what's separating these parallel
universes why isn't that universe part
of ours
and the way they always draw it is with
some black stuff
what is the black stuff space
but space is supposed to be inside the
universe not outside the universe
because the universe is not pushing up
against anything
you figure it out
you'll come to it
okay so yeah space is nothing so how do
you create nothing
you know the day god created nothing
he had not much it was a boring day
i create nothing all the time it's so
easy
it's creating something that is is
difficult but to create space no biggie
i create nothing all the time what is
nothing that which has no shape that's
the definition of science scientific
definition of space what is something
the opposite that which has shape okay
we got it that which has no shape that
which has shape
okay and uh so now we have a solution to
the problem that you know
about
whether
uh there was an origin to the universe
right there you have the clue okay
what's inside of big ben we don't know
uh
what's fueling the expansion
well they say it's that dark energy
remember we talked about the other day
that's pushing it outwards let's try and
pull it back in dark matter so we have
gravity pulling it in dark matter
and i guess energy is anti-gravity
pushing it all out against gravity i
don't know you figure it out again
uh
and they say the universe is expanding
that's a big problem because universe is
a concept and concepts typically don't
expand i mean have you ever seen the
expansion of love
or the contraction of intelligence like
in the case of mathematics
uh you know i've never seen a concept
contractor expand okay
okay so where did we get all this
nonsense okay we got it from
fellow
priest belgian priest
his name was george lemaitre
and uh in 1927 he wrote a paper after
studying it a little bit right he wrote
this paper published it published it in
french
in a french magazine and so
very few people outside of the french
world heard about this
and so it wasn't important at the time
okay
and there he gives you an idea that he
uh that he published later on in about
four years later
expanding on on his original idea and he
said the number of distinct quanta is
ever increasing if we go back in the
course of time we must find fewer and
fewer quanda you know everything coming
together the galaxies everything the
atoms everything coming together okay
until we find all the energy of the
universe packed in a few or even in a
unique quantum
a little ball a little quantum a little
singularity okay so those are the two
papers he wrote but in between 1927 1931
there was another fellow and his name
was hubble edwin hubble
and he wrote a paper in 1929
and this comes out of the wikipedia says
hubble provided evidence that the
recessional velocity of a galaxy
increases with its distance from the
earth a property now known as hubble's
law despite the fact that it had been
both proposed and demonstrated
observationally two years earlier by
george lemaitre
okay
the hubble the major law implies that
the universe is expanding okay
so this is where they got all these
ideas and uh hubble was never happy with
the fact that lemaitre beat him to it
and so he always protested and uh argued
that lemaitre really did not
figure it out like he did
but you know it's uh that's a question
of opinion if you look at the paper
i think lemaitre
you know came up with the idea so
should not be called the lameter or
hubble limit or law it should be called
the lemaitre law and that's it period
we're done uh hubble essentially copied
from the major that's essentially it
uh the idea is that for the purposes of
physics we don't care about the number
if it's going twice as fast or half as
much we don't care about that we care
about the notion the explanation the
explanation on the matrix offered is
that the universe is expanding at some
time in the past there was a singularity
okay
a quantum as he called it and from there
it all started so he started from this
little nugget
this little seed that somehow
exploded
into the universe that it's today
okay and um pius xii who was the pope at
the time he he picked up on that real
quick okay not so quick because it was a
few years after you know some 20 years
after and he said you know what you've
proven is the existence of god
it says because you know you can't have
a universe existing without a cause
the cause is god you know
and so
paul saw he had a um
a conference and he talked about that
and these were the three points that he
made says big bang universal expansion
confirms the existence of god
okay
uh it proves the origin of the universe
and you can't do it without god and the
major respondent tried to convince him
says look the origin of the universe is
a philosophical problem you know
subjective
not a scientific one objective
okay so
he kind of hinted he said you can laugh
at the mathematicians and say look we've
always told you that god was there you
didn't want to believe it because all
you people are atheists but it turns out
that you know we've all concluded now
that the universe had an origin sometime
in the past
and who created that nugget if not god
who set the whole thing in motion what
was the cause
there you have it god god himself god
almighty okay
and so um
we have other people today not
catholics but this fellow his name is
william lane craig
and he came up with a calam cosmological
argument which he defense
and will defend until his death and he
has the same argument as pope pius xii
he just picked up on that he said
whatever begins to exist has a cause of
its existence the universe began to
exist therefore the universe has a cause
and the best explanation for the cause
of the universe is
god
and so we have
god in there and the theologians are
laughing at the mathematicians because
they say see we told you that there's
always a god all you atheists who don't
believe in god you're telling me there's
a seed who created the seed well who
else but god the all-powerful the
intellect the
intelligence out there that created all
that
and so yeah the mathematicians say well
you're wrong see um
we can't tell you what happened in frame
number one we can only tell you what we
can only go as far back as frame number
two okay and so we start there and don't
get involved don't bring your god into
our discipline we promise not to take
god into your religion okay
so that's where we stand today okay one
guy says god made it all made the seed
that from where everything expanded
which the mathematicians agree with but
the mathematicians say we stop but frame
number two we don't go to frame number
one because we have no idea what
happened to frame number one that's the
story we have today
there's another issue with that and
that's uh here the flatness issue okay
and the way they explain the expansion
of the universe as you can see there you
can see they show this flat universe and
it's expanding and so they they try to
explain with this how the galaxies
originally were closer together and
with with the expansion of space what
happens is uh space is separating the
galaxies apart
okay and you say well why doesn't it
also i mean there's space be within a
galaxy
you would think that the galaxy is also
bloating like a smoking toad you know
and they say no because gravity pulls it
together maybe electromagnetism you know
magnetism for sure is
pulling all matter together while space
is trying to expand so what really
happens is you have space pushing
galaxies apart
and that's what is
that's why they say is the universe is
expanding meaning all the galaxies are
receding from the earth at least you
know at least that's the way we see it
from here from our vantage point
and they're saying yeah galaxies are
flying apart because the universe is
still exploding from the big bang
and the problem here is that they show
it as a flat surface you say why do they
put it as a flat surface where did they
get that idea well so so to put in the
proper context for you so that you know
where they got this okay and this is
where they got it okay
this is what they should be really uh
illustrating they should show a globe
here shown in two dimensions right where
you can see the galaxies were very close
together somehow these galaxies
were one on top of the other long time
ago and as space expanded right it took
the galaxies with them and separated one
from the other so the reason we
are far away from all these galaxies is
that space is expanding but then you
should see it as a globe
and and what's the issue the issues when
they talk about flatness they say well
imagine you're on a globe
well if the globe has a very small
radius
then you can see great curvature
but if it has a great radius you know
the globe gets bigger and bigger and
bigger
the surface on which you are on
you know observer again
seed touch
well the surface on which you
are standing
is
approaching flatness
okay so they're saying that it's for all
practical purposes it's
flat well you know if it's a sphere if
the universe is a sphere that's
expanding i don't care how big you want
to make that surface it's always going
to be curved
but again what's the issue the issue is
language
they talk about flatness when when the
real issue is language this is not
flatness
a curve will never be flat
and they say well it approaches flat
where do they get these notions well
from a mathematical notion which is you
know x as uh x approaches zero
so they use this notion
uh from mathematics and they say oh
we'll extrapolate it to physics if the
radius increases and the globe becomes
bigger and bigger and bigger the person
standing on there will see ever more
flatness
the highway will be flat flatter flatter
flatter and flatter the bigger the ball
gets
and so they say well
for all practical purposes it's flat
but from god's point of view out there
mother nature father universe whoever
you believe in
they still see a globe from far away
it's still a curve
it's not flat
okay so
keep all this in mind
okay so here's the balloon analogy i
talked about the other day okay you have
the balloon there's a big bang expanding
exploding and what's pushing it outwards
is the energy known as
dark energy and what's pulling it
inwards are all those galaxies known as
dark matter
it's uh dark matter that's around each
one of those galaxies and dark matter
allegedly is uh the gravitational force
that pulls everything together what's
pushing it out is dark energy they don't
know what dark matter is they don't know
what dark energy is because these are
all numbers
and what are they really well they say
we don't know what it is when they
actually tell you what it is they say
it's particles
very heavy and they are dark that's why
they're called dark dark energy dark
matter they're particles
that's all the mathematics ever proposed
and like i like to say you know it's um
it's not even dark it's transparent
translucent you can see right through
the
uh dark matter halo that surround
allegedly surrounds a galaxy you can see
the the stars and galaxies in the
background right through the halo
so uh it should not be called dark
should be called translucent transparent
invisible any of those words will be
fine
okay so uh what's the story
well some people say the universe is not
expanding we're talking about
astronomers okay famous case was this
gentleman his name was halton arp he
died a few years ago
and he had a different idea what the
redshift is because the way they proved
all these things they look at the
galaxies and they say well we're looking
at this doppler effect
the doppler effect you know for those of
you who are not familiar with it is you
know when the train comes towards you
you hear
and when it passes you go
you know
sound goes down
well they say the same thing is for
light when the light approaches you it's
blue shifted and when it recedes when it
goes away from you and droid shifted
so when they point their telescopes and
their spec
spectrometers and all these equipment
that they have in the labs they say we
see the world is all redshifted the
universe is all redshifted pretty much
okay so we have all these galaxies that
look like they're shifted redshifted
looks like they're running away from us
meaning the universe is expanding
that confirms the big bang means
everything was closer together a long
time ago and we arrive at frame number
two of the film okay that's the notion
okay
and so this uh
hutton rp he was an astronomer he was
kicked out of the united states
essentially because they wouldn't give
him any time on the telescope so he had
to go to germany came here to germany
and uh he worked here for many years
until his death
and he wrote till the end of his days uh
on a different type of redshift a
different interpretation for the
redshift okay and he said look these
guys are wrong it's not that galaxies
are receding at that the universe is
exploding and that any of that confirms
that there was a singularity in frame
number two of the film
universal film
since the redshift is not due to the
hubble expansion
or physical movement of the objects
okay keep that in mind
has a
non-cosmological or intrinsic origin he
called it intrinsic redshift okay
quasars what are they because that's
where they got some of these ideas
they're local objects ejected from the
core of active galactic nuclei okay
cosmological objects are physically
arranged in a quantized pattern around
the earth
or there is an unknown mechanism for
redshift unrelated for cosmic expansion
yes it's known as the rope hypothesis
that's the unknown mechanism that they
haven't discovered yet okay
there you see the rope and what am i
talking about well i'm talking about
this
this is the mechanism that we propose
for
uh what mr halton arp and others by the
way are still investigating this uh
propose
and here it is it's known as tired light
okay what is tired light well they said
that uh
essentially you cannot prove or you
cannot
explain in any way
uh redshift by saying that light coming
towards us is losing energy somehow the
only way the mathematicians ever came up
with that is if light hits something if
it strikes something then that something
will
uh
slow light down
and so that's how when it loses energy
as they call it right uh then at that
point you can say okay now it's red it's
going into the red zone from blue to red
because it's now approaching us and it's
approaching us hitting something losing
energy in the process
okay
so the only way they can imagine uh this
tired light mechanism which they
disagree with they say is
light can only become come towards us
redshifted and lose energy only if it
hits something
and with uh with the rope model we say
no that's not the case we we can have a
static universe totally static universe
and as
uh a rope uh recedes from or or you know
the farther away it is from its origin
from the atom that uh
to which the rope is connected
the longer the links are going to be in
the center
that's that's essentially the argument
the longer the lips links
the
lower the energy meaning you're going to
have a red shifted effect
when that happens
so we do not have to have a receding
galaxy
to
explain the mechanism of tired light we
don't have to have light strike anything
at all
all we have to have is a rope you know
famous rope here and i'm saying that if
you have uh two atoms
as you go from one atom to the next the
ropes in the center should get longer
okay that's all we're saying so we have
a mechanism to explain
uh redshift without having have anything
recede
from another the other issue you should
keep in mind is that the andromeda
galaxy is blue shifted so are other
galaxies of what is known as the local
group which are about 50 some galaxies
out there and there
i think all of them or at least most of
them are blue shifted
and you say hold it if the universe is
expanding meaning space
separating these galaxies one from the
other why are the ones in the local
groups
blue shifting you know if everything
goes according to plan
um the andromeda galaxy should hit us in
2.2 million years because apparently
it's 2.2 million light years away
meaning that if it travels at the speed
of light it should reach us in 2.2
million years
and so it's coming towards us and why is
that the case if the universe is
expanding blowing everything apart
and they say it's gravity gravity or
maybe even magnetism bringing everything
together locally
that's the answer they give you
even though they're so far away they say
well yes it's gravity that's pulling us
together
they have no evidence of that they just
that's the argument that's the ad hoc
argument to counteract anyone who
wants to say well is the universe
expanding well yeah it is expanding but
the local group is coming together
because of gravity or
magnetism who knows what maybe god
or the angels are putting it together
okay so um
what's the problem also with this notion
that the universe is expanding well it
has to do with the word universe
universe is a concept
universe stands for the word space and
matter that's what universe means
space is that which has no shape
okay and you know you cannot morph uh
space into a thing and you cannot work a
thing into space you cannot have uh
space acquire suddenly length width and
height and become a thing you cannot
have a thing lose length within height
and become space
therefore the universe is eternal
okay
nothing not even god can leave space
because space does not have a
a boundary
you know a fence
in which to cross because space is that
which has no shape it has no surface
therefore there is no
wall that you can cross to the other
side whatever that can mean uh when
something has no shape
so not even god can escape our universe
okay if he's in here somewhere
and uh
that means the universe is eternal
meaning
matter
is eternal matter cannot turn into space
space cannot turn into matter therefore
the universe is eternal
okay in both directions of time if we're
going to talk about time okay
uh the universe had no meaning matter
had no origin
and matter will have no end
it has nowhere to go
and it cannot turn into space therefore
matter has always been there whether you
like it or not
okay
okay let's move on to some of the
questions people asked uh since last
time oh just a couple more these are
like the corollary okay for you to take
home with you okay here we have god
before he created space before he
created nothing okay
that's god before he created nothing
that's what he looked like and then one
day he decided to create space okay and
that's what he looked like
because
now he had something to give him contour
he
he had no more shame
he had something to cover his shame with
which is known as space what is space
space is that which has no shape
space has serves as backdrop
to all um
matter
okay anything that's matter anything
that has shape
ultimately it has space as the backdrop
okay we got that
uh matter had no origin
neither did space
universe
quotations concept has always been there
matter has always been there
okay and now yes let's move on to the
questions
foul says as
uh c times c lacks z
what is he talking about he's saying
that um in other words right uh c
squared you know like in m c squared e
equals m c squared um the uh
he says uh has no z axis
that's what that's what the fellow is
saying it says light moves through three
axis in space not two
the speed of light times the speed of
light only describes two axes
okay
any light or image we capture from space
is a 2d representation of what we think
is a 3d event
so you're saying look
light
requires
three axis to describe it you need a x y
and z
to describe
light because light is too perpendicular
you could say right
fields
electric magnetic fields but they're in
all different directions you know one is
perpendicular to the other all around
so it's really a 3d thing that's saying
and you need that z axis to get that
third dimension
so we represented a c squared meaning
two axis when it's really a c cube
phenomenon which we are representing as
c squared looking at it or seeing it in
two dimensions
that's his argument
okay so uh how do we counter this we're
saying that
uh none of this has anything to do with
the c squared
this is what c squared stands for under
the rope model it's a total different
view for what c squared stands for and
here it is c squared is torsion
propagates to and from every atom in the
universe
okay
and so it's uh two and fro
means that one atom torques uh pumps at
pumps uh torsion waves along the rope to
every atom in the universe and every
atom in the universe pumps torsion waves
to it
that's what c squared means it's got
nothing to do with x y z mathematical
number lines which is what these people
really are talking about okay
so uh no uh we
will counter what this gentleman said
it's got nothing to do with the xyz axis
of mathematics
certainly
not with number lines which is what
mathematics uses it has no use for
true dimensions of physics
or coordinates of physics or vectors of
physics
meaning those lines are perpendicular
and to each other and
have direction
mathematics has no use for qualitative
concepts such as
perpendicularity or
direction
mathematics only has magnitude no
direction what is time
a number line not any dimension not a
vector not a
coordinate it's a number line
time has
magnitude but no direction
if you believe otherwise plea point
in the direction do it with the right
hand pointing in the direction which
time flows for you
because for me it points in that
direction you know how about for you
does it point in that direction
time has no direction okay the arrow of
time
has no point to it
okay another fellow says here he says uh
charlatan claim charlatans claim that
energy hasn't been defined
and then he defines his energy the
capacity to do work
okay so if he defined it and he defined
it as capacity both right so we have two
issues one he defined it we only define
concepts and he defines it as capacity
which is a concept obviously energy is
not a thing
okay that's the first one we're gonna
say so you can't use energy as a thing
you can't use energy as a baseball bat
and says energy do does this or energy
does that i'm gonna transfer energy
you can't transfer concepts can't
transfer capacity
so energy is not a physical object
according to this guy's own
definition but then he says there are
types of energy we don't fully
understand
yeah you can't understand it and let me
tell you why here we have uh someone who
outranks him his name was uh
uh richard feynman put this up several
times it is important to realize that in
physics today we have no knowledge of
what energy is
that's a nobel prize would i which i
think outranks this poor little fellow
here here right uh he doesn't have any
idea what energy is but he says it's
capacity and capacity is not an is it's
not a what it's a it's a concept and if
it's a concept
then you can't talk about
doing anything with it because there's
no such thing as you know you can't you
can't do anything with energy because
it's like saying i'm gonna move
intelligence around i'm going to
move love around
or i'm going to transfer love how do you
transfer love you catch it with your
hand and
i hope it doesn't drip through your
hands you know same with energy does it
go right through your hands
how do you how do you move a concept
okay so this is the issue it says we are
still capable of using their capacity
he's going to use energy how do you use
energy you grab with your tweezers with
your hands how do you use it
now we can't use energy because it's a
concept we don't use console you can use
a hammer you can use a i don't know a
measuring rod you can use a slide rule
you can't use
concepts okay
and
that's if you want to do technology
again that's got nothing to do with
science
and who can
also measure the we can also measure the
fields of these energies and apply
mathematical values
yeah that's got nothing to do with
science okay
and so yeah a field here's what we have
to do a field okay
we look at the definition what is a
field says in the religion of
mathematics right physics right
a field is a physical quantity
whatever physical quantity is it's a
quantity it's a number
that has a value for each point in space
okay so in mathematics a field is what a
set a fundamental uh algebraic um
structure whatever structure
means
it's a bunch of numbers that's what a
field is
field is just a mathematical
representation
of values around an object a property
usually applied to magnetic electric and
gravitational so-called fields what are
those those
are simply
[Music]
values
they measure something and say there's a
value here and there's a value over
there numbers that's all they are
numbers follow by units that's it
so they can tell you how strong a
gravitational field or a magnetic field
is here there and over there
and the sum of that that's called the
field
but they treat field as a physical
object they say well the field did this
and the field did that
you can't do that with concepts in
physics you can't use the field as a
baseball bat
okay that's the problem okay you can't
use the word field as a physical object
and another problem here similar fellow
does the make the same error with
another word the word plasma okay foul
says plasma is the magneto dielectric
force that
constitutes the ether and which is the
electrostatic attraction and or
repulsion which makes gravity the
experiment that demonstrates this force
has been shown in this video where a
beam of light is passed through the
plasma ether and bends reflects that
light
bends light refracts light reflect could
be i don't know about bending you know
again
uh
if light is a photon i don't know how
you bend it if it's a wave i don't know
how you bend it how do you bend maybe
you're talking about deflecting
okay and again all these people use the
wrong language they never learned to
speak because they never learned the
basics of physics
they never took a an introductory course
in physics
probably
from the electric universe very likely
the same mathematics that explains
gravity also fits perfectly with
calculations of that electrostatic force
attraction when moving towards large
massive objects example the stars or
planets moons etc
okay we just addressed the issue of
plasma okay and here it is okay plasma
is not a physical object
plasma is a concept just like energy is
a concept just like field is a concept
you can't use the word plasma as a
physical object you can't use it
as a baseball bat as a
racket
tennis racket you can't use it as that
and these people have never understood
what an object is what a thing is they
never define the word thing the word
object
and they think uh plasma is an object
they think plasma is a thing
they say what do you mean i can see it
yeah an object is not that which you can
see but i can touch it and an object is
not that which you can touch
you can't defend those two definitions
you have to go with a scientific
definition an object is that which has
shape they say well an object plasma has
shape see i can see it and so it's got
to have shape
no plasma doesn't have shape because
plasma means what ionized
ionized ionize is an adjective or an ad
or a verb depending on how you
use it right
ionize means something is happening
and there you see what is happening the
electrons the blue little dots are
leaving their atoms something is
happening to the atoms
plasma is a process
a process of ionization
and these people are so mentally
[ __ ] takes them more than two years
or sometimes never to learn
that plasma is not a physical object
okay takes them a long time to learn
that plasma is not a physical object
plasma is a process of something that is
ongoing
okay and then they say well it's a state
of matter
well i don't know if it's a state of the
union or if it has you know if it's a
51st star on the flag
uh state
like saying you have solid you get gas
you got liquid if it's a state then it's
a concept for sure
and so a state of matter
is not the same thing as ionized gas or
ionized atoms
and they don't even realize that they
just say well it's a state of matter
it's ionized gas it's an object
no it's not an object not in not in
science
in the religion of mathematics it could
be
an object not in science and if you
don't like the definition of
object of science that which has shape
what do you have to do you have to come
up with a better mousetrap and you have
to be able to defend your definition
with sword and shield
inside
the coliseum
with that i'll see you next